it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we expose the stories
behind the headlines and for that we
turn to fox news contributor raymond
arroyo
all right raymond during our trip to
orlando i
understand that you wandered off from
the crew
and you went talking to voters random
people on the street what happened
i did i asked them about biden's four
trillion dollar
infrastructure plan which he's selling
out on the road
i'll show you that in a moment but i
started by asking voters this
penetrating question laura if you had to
rate
biden's first hundred days on a scale
from one to five being the best
you would rate him what suck describe
why
suck it's un-american it's absolutely
un-american
one why was i like trump better
is that my only choice one to five
because my real answer is
minus to the infinite degree
and 80. and 80. why why
because i think he's come through on
some issues that are important to the
public
like what
i think he's writing checks frivolously
i have a business background i don't
know how he's going to fund
all of this just keep giving people free
things and they're going to just want
more
let me see what i think
i didn't hear his speech last night you
can either
be given free stuff or become
free you got two choices that's it
he's calm and he doesn't lie i think
he's trying
but i think his actions speak louder
than his words in terms of
in terms of dividing the country well if
you don't see somebody for 100 days
how can you even rate them there was a
lot of consternation over the
president's infrastructure plan laura
even from some of biden's supporters all
told this is a six
trillion dollar plan whether you call it
infrastructure or the american job acts
in 2019 the entire federal government
spent four trillion dollars
we're now talking about blowing that and
two trillion
more people are watching and they're
none too happy
all we need to do is open up the entire
economy there's pent-up demand there's
plenty of people
plenty of job openings in the uh red
states this is a complete and utter joke
and we shouldn't call it the
infrastructure
it's not about infrastructure it's about
changing the structure of america
and raymond amazingly biden is also
trying to get taxpayers to spend
80 billion dollars on money losing
amtrak
right he didn't have some sentimental
pitch uh the other day complete with
his little motorman hat i used to like
to take the train home my mom was
sick and i'd come try to come home
almost every weekend
if you think about it when we were
when i was vice president with barack he
allowed me to put together
a budget for amtrak and it had money for
high-speed rail
at 200 miles an hour from
from uh uh assuming from charlotte
one another line going from
in florida down to tampa another line if
we had moved go we'd have that tunnel
fixed in new york now
the money was there to get it done laura
this is
as confusing as amtrak's new lines okay
maybe we should spend trillions to bring
back trolleys and horse-drawn carriages
i mean let those horses do their fair
share ingram
uh this is the biggest boondoggle amtrak
lost 700 million dollars last year
despite a billion dollars in emergency
cash and nearly 30 million in the year
before
it's a dying mode of transportation he
wants back on the atchison topeka and
the santa fe
when he should be exploring flying cars
and self-driving vehicle highways
that's forward-looking he says it's a
once-in-a-lifetime investment
no it's a lifetime investment laura 81
billion so far and as you said earlier
no profit turned
right all he plays to those little train
sets in the oval office and he imagines
himself
riding the rails once again what else
well today the president and dr jill
biden visited a school in virginia
to push his teacher union funding i mean
his
public education and school expansion
plan perhaps a speechwriter stimulus is
what's really needed
just like
just like lovely lady
in blue over here as a professor at
community college
there's so much that happens when they
don't have the
certitude and the and the companionship
and the familiarity being with their
friends
there's an awful lot of need in this
pandemic
for mental health facilities if i didn't
have these positions i'd be sleeping in
a lincoln bedroom
rather than the vice the president's
bedroom
laura he said and jill keeps telling him
any country that out
educates us will out compete us but the
biden plan
would pay for illegals to go to college
for free i don't see how that helps
america but maybe it helps other
countries
i kept i kept thinking jill was going to
come by and say
the tapioca is now being offered in the
library
it was just pet champ you'll be fine god
bless raymond thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else